all right a tradition unlike any other
or something mbs shireen williams and
mike florio here with our awards for
week 11. we do it every tuesday on pftpm
hello to mds and let's get right into it
we don't have a lot of time so mds
offensive player of the week week 11 go
jared goff had a season high 376 yards
and three touchdowns against the
buccaneers on monday night he looked
very comfortable against the bucks
defense that has made a lot of
quarterbacks uncomfortable and i believe
if he keeps playing like this the rams
are real contenders to get to the super
bowl
how about another team that's a real
contender and the top contender now for
the mvp award mds and that's patrick
mahomes and you know we sort of take him
for granted because he seems to do it
week in and week out but i talked to a
raiders official this week and he said
you know when we scored and there was
143 left on the clock i knew we were in
trouble with patrick mahomes there andy
reid said it i've got pat mahomes he
probably made mrs mahomes mother my
home's a little bit mad might call him
pat
but
patrick holmes did it again he was
outstanding in winning that game against
the raiders
yeah i have a feeling andy reid has
slightly more sway in the mahomes
household than louis riddick does but
that was one of the classic moments
earlier this year when randy mahomes
decided to tweet during the game please
get my son's name right deshawn watson
has had a very challenging season with
the houston texans they were two and
seven entering the game against the new
england patriots i thought it was the
easiest play of the week the patriots
only giving two points to the texans are
you kidding me the texans are
dysfunctional all they have is desean
watson we know what bill belichick does
he takes away what the other team does
best all the other team does is let
desean watson do his thing surely
they'll be able to shut him down yada
yada yada the end result was desean
watson takes down the patriots and there
was a moment where he pulled his way
into the end zone and he is not nearly
thick enough to be bullying anyone but i
almost felt like in that moment that was
where a full year of frustration came
out and it's i'm sick of this crap and
he just decided he was going to make
that score because who knows whether
anyone else on the offense could be
trusted to get into the end zone so i
was impressed with knowing the opponent
knowing the approach knowing that he was
the focal point of everything they were
doing defensively to shut him down for
him to have the game he did get a pride
win for the texans at a time when it
would be very easy to just throw in the
towel to the benefit of miami dolphins
because the dolphins hold the first and
second round picks of the houston texans
so on a rare occasion the dolphins
rooting for the patriots on sunday if
they were rooting for anyone didn't work
out texans get their third win of the
year who knows how many more wins they
will get but i think that's one that
really should make us appreciate desean
watson even more all right let's flip it
over to the defensive side of the ball
mds who's your week 11 defensive player
of the week
my defensive player of the week is
olivier vernon who knew the browns
needed him to step up in a big way with
miles garrett out because of covert 19
and vernon did step up in a big way
three sacks against the eagles and you
know vernon took a pay cut this season
and said one of the reasons he was
willing to do that was he wants to play
on a playoff team and he thinks the
browns are a playoff team and that may
sound insane given the browns recent
history but i don't think it is insane
this year i think the browns may very
well be heading to the playoffs
mds there were so many defensive players
was really hard to pick you could have
gone with any of those steelers or jj
watt i went with donovan wilson and
anytime i could pick an aggie you know
it's a good day but
the question i have is why it took the
cowboys so long to put donovan wilson
back there at safety he started the last
six games and you know when he was
at a m the ncaa actually changed the
rule after you left the targeting rule
that said if you have more than two
targeting penalties in a year you're
subject to suspension he had three in
one season this guy can hit hard who
knows what else he can do but he can hit
hard and he you saw that with the hit on
cousins which was a helmet to helmet hit
he'll be fine for but he took the ball
away and then the hard hit on uh dalvin
cook that forced another fumble so we
had two fumbles and a fumble recovery
and i thought he just really made a
a difference in that cowboys defense
that if he keeps playing like that the
cowboys have a chance to go to playoffs
they need defensive help and he helped
him
such a weird comment the cowboys have a
chance to go to the playoffs because of
their record but because of their
division they do and i really think
whoever wins on thursday is going to
have that glow coming from the big spot
tryptophan bowl every year the big red
kettle will be out there i have a
feeling that the winner and i don't know
i'm gonna make my picks tomorrow it may
be the cowboys going to four and seven
and maybe in great position to win the
division for me it's cam jordan the
saints defense has been phenomenal the
past few weeks we get so caught up in
the offense and will the offense play
better and what's drew brees going to do
can he get the ball down the field and
where's michael thomas and is he healthy
and what's he going to do and here's
alvin kamara and what's taysom hill's
role before drew brees was injured now
how's taysom hill going to do at
quarterback we forget about the defense
cam jordan had three sacks they held the
buccaneers to three points in that
sunday night game they shut down the
49ers which isn't hard to do without
jimmy garoppolo on the field but they
still did it and then to hold the
falcons when they had two weeks to get
ready for the game to single digits that
is a testament to a great defense in new
orleans they're as balanced as anyone in
the nfc i think right now it's a toss-up
between the saints and the rams for the
best team in the nfc
hopefully they're on a collision course
to meet in the postseason and hopefully
the officials will be ready to call any
and all pass interference that may
happen if the saints and rams meet again
all right rookie of the week time mds
who do you have
i have justin herbert who threw for
three touchdowns on sunday that was his
fifth
three touchdown game in only nine career
starts that is unprecedented in nfl
history for a quarterback to do that
that quickly that five three touchdown
games in just
nine career starts
he's playing great football i think the
chargers still have quite a bit of work
to do with building their roster but wow
do they ever have a good young
quarterback
mike you talked about whoever wins
thursday's game against between dallas
and washington has a good chance to win
the nfc east well i think we're going to
get a big dose of antonio gibson he's
been very good rookie third round draft
pick he had 16 carries for 94 yards and
a touchdown in helping take the pressure
off of alex smith in that victory over
cincinnati so going to see more of him
this week and more of him this year
yeah and look whoever as i said wins
that game on thursday is going to be in
great great shape to win the division
i'm going to go with joe burrow
just because number one it's
very sad and depressing to see such a
promising young player done for the year
and he did have a very special season
and he he deserves to be appreciated for
what he did for the bengals i'm still a
little frustrated the bengals didn't do
a better job of protecting him the hit
that he took on his leg if you haven't
seen it yet don't go look for it
i don't know that that he'll be back in
time for the start of next season i hope
they don't take any chances with the kid
i saw booger mcfarland arguing last
night they should treat next year as a
redshirt season but joe burrow was on
pace to do some really great things as a
rookie he did some great things he
turned that team around he made a team
that had been boring for several years
interesting and i just hope he's back
sooner than later it looks like it's
going to be a long road and hopefully he
can recover from it and and maybe be
back by week one but above all else be
back when he's healthy and ready to go
coach of the week mds who do you have
i have matt rule you know the panthers
have had a lot of injuries uh most
notably teddy bridgewater and christian
mccaffrey were both out sunday and yet
they absolutely dominated the lions that
that was just an impressive performance
by the panthers look you can say
what is a game between the panthers and
the lions late in the season even mean
but what it means to me is matt rule has
the players out there playing hard i
think there's still a lot of work to do
in developing that roster but i think
the panthers found the right coach to do
it in that rule and i think the proof is
in how hard they played for him in
difficult circumstances on sunday
mds i think we saw the genius that is
sean payton again at work on sunday and
the
the saints now are 6-0 without drew
brees over the last two years with teddy
bridgewater 5-0 last season and now take
some hill and they just seem to find a
way to win no matter who's at
quarterback and he's just done an
outstanding job again this season and i
have total faith that he will continue
to do that once drew brees retires he's
just shown it again and again and again
that the saints are going to be a
contender from now on
you know it's been a rough day for the
cowboys organization because of the
situation with marcus paul they shut
down practice we don't have all the
details yet and we'll wait for the team
to release the details before we provide
them but mike mccarthy after the bye
week getting it together and knocking
off a team that we were just checking
off the wins oh cowboys there's a win
panthers there's a win jaguars there's a
win getting his guys ready to go to
minnesota and win that game with the
gallagher homage and the sledgehammers
to the watermelons whatever it takes
baby whatever you got to do to get your
guys motivated he pressed the right
buttons he got it done and the cowboys
were ready to go out and get the win and
now they're in position to double their
win total in just five days from sunday
to thursday and if they do that they
will be in business maybe mike mccarthy
will jump in the salvation army kettle
not ezekiel elliott at some point on
sunday as long as he doesn't take a
sledgehammer to it
all is fair once they roll out the
kettle for the holiday season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports